c'est le brin de bas de combat à
Khartoum les convois d'évacuation se
multiplient dans les rues de la capitale
l'autobus de ressortissants étrangers
ont fui le Soudan dans les dernières
heures
la Grande-Bretagne la France et les
États-Unis ont tous évacué leur
ambassade le président américain Joe
Biden a d'ailleurs retenu à remercier le
Djibouti l'Éthiopie et l'Arabie Saoudite
pour leur soutien et saoudiens sont en
fait un roi-je important de ces nombreux
évacuations eux qui transportent depuis
hier des ressortissants des quatre coins
du monde le Port Soudan jeda de l'autre
côté de la mer Rouge mais à cartoon tous
n'ont pas la chance d'être évacués
dans son appartement cet étudiante
Canado soudanaise attend des nouvelles
d'une évacuation canadienne mais le
gouvernement ne prévoit pas ce genre
d'opération pour l'instant sur Twitter
la ministre des Affaires étrangères dit
avoir pris la décision de suspendre
temporairement les opérations
canadiennes au Soudan nous donnerons en
contact avec les Canadiens touchés par
cette crise et leur fournissant des
informations et des conseils
ajoute-t-elle en fait le Canada gère la
situation en fonction des moyens que
nous avons sur place le soudain est un
pays où nous avons un petit programme de
coopération et une petite ambassade on
dépend beaucoup notre ambassade en
Éthiopie qui est beaucoup plus gros
c'est beaucoup plus important
et signe que les combats pourraient
s'intensifier dans les prochains jours
de nombreuses vidéos publiées sur les
réseaux sociaux montrent l'arrivée de
nouveaux bataillons dans la capitale
soudanais ici Xavier Radio-Canada
Montréal